alors que jamel debbouze kev adams et
vanessa qui les rigoles ou quoi que donc
la musique havas avec il veut que les
que cyril si je tiens à dire quelque
chose d'incroyable eux deux une chiche
[Rires]
les vols décollent chaque fois à chaque
fois quand c'est la dernière fois que tu
m'as fait un carrosse je t'ai dit la
prochaine fois en très sobre qui m'a dit
toi tu m'a dit je te jure la prochaine
rentrée simple une babouche en forme de
tonnes c'est alain trussart d'y aller
celui qui n'a jamais été seul au moins
une fois dans sa vie
m
l'auteur de solos de la nuit
[Applaudissements]
oui
le collier c'est la maison et devrait
dire un 100m et regarder dedans il ya
docteur mais aux tubes comme ça qu'est
ce que tu as well as the amazing en fait
et quand on vient un mec qui te brassens
et que j'essaye et loire oise elle vous
explique il a donné vie barre de la
fortune thank you for attention défi en
2007 il va se faire celui-ci
[Applaudissements]
leïla
est-ce que vous collez est ce que vous
êtes tous contents de jouer avec
christian clavier
franchement c est ce que c'est un
aboutissement moi je sais que quand je
le reçois dans l'émission enfin je sais
je suis je suis c'est je le dis
aujourd'hui et je le dis voilà une fois
pour toute et je ne changerai pas d'avis
1 c'est mon invité préférées ouais je le
dis et c'est vrai la numéro 1 et tous
les autres peuvent maps et peuvent le
dire ici tout ça et là ils n'ont qu'à
plus venir voilà mais je le dis mais ça
l'équipe et ça me fait ça qui fait ça
qui dit on voit les fautes et les mecs
non ça rigolait qui envoie les qui
envoie les photos et envoyait photo cg
moi je veux un nom c'est moi qui est
avec tout mon cas
[Musique]
comme c'est parti je vous aime beaucoup
je suis très content de ce bras pour
garder les jeux de 20 heures dans la
région en général vous participez
parfois la voix j'étais chez ma mère on
a mangé là il vaut rien d après les jeux
chez maman j'ai mal joué ou ça vous
habitez paris
j'habite paris tout à paris même paris
même proche est lui bien dans paris et
seulement on circule bien non par heinze
avait ainsi coude alors mais tu veux pas
me réveiller et ont répété je ne
répéterai plus jamais tu promets je le
promets tu crois qu'ils s'appellent va
réussir ces six athlètes a répété toi le
divino mais jamais je crois qu'on a fêté
avec des copains les la fouine je te
jure que non
[Applaudissements]
et
j'allais me is you
le public attention
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
les chéris merci encore à télé loisirs
novare discerner voilà le halal award du
meilleur animateur pour moi j'aurais mis
issa doumbia
voilà je vous le dis on va quoi bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non j'ai vu que ce matin quoi le
meilleur animateur c'était moi alors toi
tu étais meilleur animateur de télé de
tv mag habré tv mag
alors à calais si on perd peut lui
amener quelque chose si au ps qu'on peut
lui mettre quelque chose d'une grotte on
amer attendait ses animateurs préférés
des français
c'est la première fois que michel cymes
et ils sont battus voilà bah tu veux que
je te dise préfère prendre mon rendu
notre envie de le dire je préfère que ce
soit toi ça prétend que c'est soit on
fait du giscop année est ce qu'on peut
emmener gestion play la couronne pour t
merci
[Applaudissements]
et
stevan jusqu'à ben moi j'aime pas les
gros trucs alors j'ai fait un petit truc
comme ça toi pour fêter j'aime pas les
célébrations mais y en a d'autres choix
en pole galère au mcee la musique
[Musique]